good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so I
hope on your journey today's message is
a lot of people don't want except over
you my well a lot of people don't really
want success I've never understood that
this is true it's intimate because they
don't want it and the best evidence of
that is that avail they sail and abettor
best evidence of that is they don't try
sunshine right that's right but to
succeed means that means you're in front
of God and and lots of responsible
people and you have to to either eat
your words or or stand by them I think
that I have agreed a long time ago
Charlie Rose this may be what I might
make greatest blessing I agreed long a
long time ago that I would die
now if I can admit that that no matter
what happens I will do this thing this
is the biggest Bugaboo of them all I
will do that well then why couldn't I
attempt something better
yeah so I will try your fear of failure
has done more to harm you than any
insult in western ND your fear failure
is done more to harm you this any
speeding that anybody's ever put on you
you're revealed earlier is the biggest
and it's holding you back from achieving
amazing things and building amazing
companies and just making failure all
it's not doing the thing that you want
to do nothing the thing that is inside
you that you know if you did it it's
going to be amazing but there's a huge
wall of fear you have to break through
and I think need to have discussion
around here I think you see fear as the
negative fear is the enemy
we should do anything that we're afraid
of but if you look at all the people
that you look up to all the people in
respect
Ashley's entrepreneurs musicians who
ever did he looked up to they had an
insane amount of fear to get to where
they wanted to go there's a great
diagram at the t-shirt of it about the
comfort zone where it shows where your
comfort zone is and it shows where the
magic happens and the magic always have
to detect your comfort zone and the
morning constructions and more you can
push what makes you scared then the more
you can to create for yourself for your
community for your friends into the
world if you just stay within this
bubble we never do the thing that you're
afraid of you never going to grow and
you ever really going to be happy and
the end of your life smell about to be
filled with regrets as we didn't do this
thing there's been a lot of times that
Lisa mean I'm sure you can relate
there's something I was so afraid to do
I was so afraid to do it and then what
they did it like you know what that she
was enough up and you do it over and
over and over again the fear is building
on I think about many videos on YouTube
the first times I have a friend of each
camera I had this as my sister someone
on my team coming in and my own camera
focused it and is leave the room because
I was too afraid of their judgement to
their community even though they really
care they were actually supportive of me
but I was just too afraid to talk in
front of somebody else when I was
walking on the street and filmed it
myself I'd be too afraid of other people
their judgments they're looking in
destroy me off and so if I let that
prevent me from actually making videos
then I was having this I would be
helping you guys you wouldn't have
anything to watch for me on a regular
basis right I wouldn't have cloisonne
lost 800,000 subscribers would we happen
and that would be a huge hole for me
that makes me feel really bad like
that's what h9e looking back to my life
say I need to do that because
try to the camera please open for me
that's how I get through the immediate
here is i fast-forward to the end of my
life and i trade off this immediate tiny
little fear getting up in front of a
camera doing something versus an entire
lifetime of regret and that's what i
want to try to avoid and so failure is
going to happen failure is going to
happen people fail the most excessive
people who won't fail over and over and
over and over and over again they fail
they fail away success
everybody is had massive failures if you
don't have any feelings that means you
haven't tried anything and just don't be
afraid of fades I just trying to make
Bailey's on a small scale a lot of the
videos that we made for this YouTube
channel don't know anywhere series die
all the time the top 10 was just one
that I did as a one-off and it did well
because gonna get do it again let's do
it quite moving three times in five
times a week and the Phils and others I
don't remember how many we've killed off
you just I'm going to apply it it's just
part of the distant past I don't
remember the Navy is a series anymore I
love them when I launch something and
you guys it releases them as well so we
killed it and I expect most things to
fail that's okay I don't tie my
self-worth to one idea working out so if
you can do that you get past the fear of
failure and just expect things not to
work at the beginning and just keep
driving keep improving it advances
nothing they desire beginning works
everything you do will fail out the
beginning I need to tell you try to
learn you're going to suck at at the
start it's normal if you trying to learn
a language or pick up a new skill you're
going to go snowboarding or mess with
biking or learn how to move you tube or
lights or whatever it is you're going to
suck at at the start that's okay a song
expect it embrace it and then you're
going to continue to fail and not get so
caught up on every failures damaging
your psyche so much and there's the
other end and this is where models in
such good health by looking at these
people and knowing that they made it
through that
with it and you embrace failure you keep
going and keep working we keep hustling
that eventually you'll be good through
just like they did but if you quit and
you stop and you won't be so fact the
busier phrase then you're going to
continue to live the life that you're
going to regret instead of doing the
things that you're going to do so the
question today is I'm curious what is
the thing that you are most afraid of
write these down comment below really
curious kinda I also want to give a
quick chance to represent as zoom
remember thinking so much as picked up a
cup of my foot your one word I really
appreciate you support and I hope you
enjoy this week so thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you he'll
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow more a for another shot of its
better
away he goes
Socrates had practice death daily giving
me back in a morbid sense he meant that
if we really consciously realize and
remember every day that we are all going
to die then we live life differently
because first of all we don't sweat the
small stuff and when it comes to death
everything is small stuff it's the same
thing you know that and the Romans
thought you know they would carve on
statues and on trees and men memento
mori
remember death again it's one of the
thing I am we actually have now a
dedicated reporter on the Huffington
Post covering death because again just
again a huge silence in our culture but
the thing that is the absolutely
inevitable part of our lives is not
being covered by the media the Columbia
Journalism Review is first name is Kjell
we'd be done if you can't remember his
last name is that he is doing amazing
things around that in our religion
section which is next to a science
section because increasingly we're
trying to to see how the two are not
opposed to each other you know dogmas
may be opposed but the heart of every
religion is very connected to the heart
of huge scientific discoveries so my
point to go back to death
justice position and is that if we make
it part of life it will make us lead
life differently and so when the time
comes for us to die we will be prepared
for it
yeah because we practice because we have
practiced it every day I tell people all
the time and I really believe this that
as I exist to show people what's
possible I really do
that's how it's like go for it try it
because another thing I am no different
and anyone else out there I am NOT here
to say I have a superpower and it was
all this it was just try it go but let's
see what happened yeah and all the
things will you get rid of judgment now
you can be creative but any bit of
judgment kills creativity anytime you
start to go well maybe I shouldn't
it's funny because you look at a
lip-sync or you look at any kind of
dancing or anything like that as soon as
people seen being inhibited you're done
you're like oh no this guy what is that
but all they want just easily kill all
you got just put it out there and that
and then everybody's with you and let me
tell you Terry Crews is going to give
you a hundred and fifty percent no
matter what and as I learned that's my
whole career yeah you should just
observe if everybody makes an licking
effort everybody take a little time for
this piece of life okay not for your
family not for your carrier not for
something else something else just for
this piece of life give it a little time
because this is the most important piece
of life in your life isn't it
I said no even if you're in love with
somebody still this is the most
important piece of life isn't it so pay
some attention to this how does it
happen why have you taken it for granted
believe me you're not going to be here
forever
I'll bless you with a long life but
you're going to fall that one day yes or
no yes so do not take this for granted
if you wake up in the morning tomorrow
if you wake up in the morning
now it's not my wish but I want you to
know of all the people who go to bed
tonight over a million people will not
wake up tomorrow morning and tomorrow if
you and we wake up tomorrow morning is
it not a fantastic thing a million
people did not wake up you woke up is it
not a great thing just look at the
ceiling and smile you are still awake
you still there
and for many many millions of people
somebody whose dear to them did not wake
up so just check those five six people
around you they all woke up wow it's a
fantastic day
you woke up and everybody who matters to
you around you woke up
is it not fantastic day you don't think
so yes you don't seem to think so
see because the problem is just this you
are living with an idea that you are
immortal when I say you're the model
you're not actually thinking you're
immortal but you are not conscious of
your Morales mortality if you are not
conscious of your mortality somewhere
you think you're immortal isn't it how
many moments in a day are you conscious
that you're mortal
if you were conscious would you have
time to crib would you have time to
fight with somebody would you have time
to do some rubbish with your life if you
knew if you are conscious that you're
mortal you would do nothing other than
what is absolutely needed for you and
everybody around you this one thing if
you do if you just remind yourself you
don't think this is a negative thing
that is not a negative thing it's the
only thing which is added value to your
life if you are here forever you would
be unbearable yes
yes isn't it aren't we glad everybody
dies one day if you just become
conscious of this one thing that always
you're conscious that I'm mortal you
don't have to think I will die today we
don't intend we want to live as far as
possible just you know one day I will
die if you just conscious of this one
thing you will naturally become
spiritual every day every moment if you
remind yourself this is a brief life and
motto one day I will end just to do this
for two days and see you will become
something truly fantastic within
yourselves just this is all and it's
simply beautiful that's all that's
needed if you want to know the value of
life just know that it's a brief
happening